buying a car can be a stressful time but
the people at chapman automotive want to
make it as easy as possible for you and
your family so joining us now is don
hamrick president of the mata operations
and welcome back nice to be back
cracking thanks nice to see you last
time you were in the kitchen now you're
here i was cooking
now i hear there are some new changes to
the dealership what's going on so all
kinds of fun things we just opened our
new store on boulder highway and next
week we do a complete remodel on our
store on east saharan mojave it's going
to become an exclusively jeep store in
about six months i love a jeep i know
everybody loves their jeans i know
they're so cool now some people are
holding off right now on the big you
know the big
purchases like a car right how are you
guys adjusting so what we've been able
to do um the the money that we've
invested in our community manufacturers
actually given us extra cars as well so
we've earned a special allocation okay
we're able to pass those on to our
clients and even though there's been a
little uptick in interest rates it
hasn't made a dramatic difference in
payments for people so we're still
helping people get cars and it's a great
time to buy that is good to know now
does that mean the supply chain is
coming back it's because that's been a
hundred percent a long time but it's
better than it was
and we still have a great selection of
uh brand new vehicles and late model
pre-owned vehicles as well and great
opportunities there too so even if
you're buying a car and you're trading
something in your your trade's never
been worth more either so it works out
both ways okay good to know and it's
your new dealership that you mentioned
is that fully operational yet so our
store opened last week okay it's fully
operational what's been great i think as
much as the fact that our clients love
it are i think we're looking at it right
now that's it and it looks even better
in real life that's just one of those
like pictures right but um our employees
are so happy so everybody's getting
greeted with a big smile they're being
welcome most of our people are just kind
of playing tour guide and taking people
around and showing them everything okay
now what's happening at the at the
location that chapman left so that's the
one that's going to become the exclusive
jeep store so we're going to break
ground um next week start taking that
and expanding out we're picking up 2 450
square feet
and we're going to have an exclusive
area for just jeep wagoneer for the
wranglers the gladiators it will be all
the jeeps and all their glory and then a
lifestyle section so people can buy hats
and t-shirts and you know all the things
that go with being a jeep owner
everybody loves the swag the jeep's
black
swag next time oh yeah no you you bring
it you bring it now you're offering this
you always help the community but this
one's a big one all right you're
offering your new car buyers free gas
for yes for 90 days when you buy a car
free gas for 90 days and no payments for
90 days we're calling it our free ride
you know come on and take a free ride so
it's been really really good people have
enjoyed that they've come in depending
on the car you choose is is the the
amount we give towards free gas and you
get that for three months 90 days that
is the ride that i'm willing to take
that's a good ride
thank you so much all right thank you to
chapman automotive for sponsoring call
702-457-1061
or head to las vegas dodge dot com that
free ride for 90 days no payments and
free gas for 90 days with new car
purchase or lease can't do better than
that
[Music]